let's take a closer look at how the
biden administration is handling the
renewed focus on the border crisis
here's white house correspondent peter
ducey
a rare admission from this white house
they know the headlines are bad we're in
the middle of navigating and weathering
storms and and dealing with crises
that's what a president should do the
u.s envoy for haiti wants out daniel
foote resigned with this letter i will
not be associated with the united states
inhumane counterproductive decision to
deport thousands of haitian refugees and
illegal immigrants to haiti a country
where american officials are confined to
secure compounds because of the danger
posed by armed gangs to daily life the
white house is pushing back i would note
there have been multiple senior level
policy conversations on haiti where all
proposals including those
led by special envoy foot were fully
considered some of those proposals were
harmful to our commitment to the
promotion of democracy in haiti
progressives are still upset some
migrants were rounded up by mounted
border patrol officers patrols that have
since been suspended what we witnessed
was worse than what we witnessed in
slavery the white house is hoping to
cool criticism i think
congresswoman waters and others as are
we have been horrified by the photos of
the border patrol
officers and that behavior but incoming
from the left is uncommon for this
president president biden getting
attacks from both sides of the aisle is
because he can't get a handle on this
situation to clear the camp in del rio
the feds are bussing migrants to parts
of texas or flying them to arizona and
unless they show symptoms no covet tests
why should somebody say in laredo texas
or el paso or tucson arizona have to
have their chance of catching covet go
up because hundreds of miles away there
is an open border well there certainly
is not an open border there is according
to some texas lawmakers most of these
haitians are from brazil they got word
of the fact that you know with the biden
administration we have an open border
policy come on in that's exactly what
biden said two years ago we're a nation
says if you want to flee and you're
fleeing oppression you should come
when the president said that
progressives cheered but now that people
are actually coming
progressives are telling him you've got
to treat these migrants better and
president biden is saying nothing no
public events on the schedule today
right peter ducey live on the north lawn
peter thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else